American President Joe Biden has
approved 800 million dollars in
additional military assistance to
Ukraine the package includes Heavy
Artillery as Keith prepares to defend
against a massive Russian assault
expected in the east of the country
satellite images have shown large
convoys of Russian military vehicles
converging in and near the donbass
region
mariu pole is in Ruins after weeks of
Russian bombardment
the U.S says it is once again sending
arms to Ukraine to stop Russia's
destruction of the country
uh today
the president announced and authorized
another
presidential drawdown of security
assistance valued at up to an additional
800 million dollars
tailored to meet
urgent Ukrainian needs for today's fight
as Russian forces shift the focus of
their ruthless aggression now to Eastern
Ukraine Ukraine's president expressed
his gratitude we've agreed on 800
million dollars in military aid for
weapons ammunition artillery helicopters
and more I am sincerely thankful for the
support
you throw
the need for more arms is urgent as
Russian convoys Converge on eastern
Ukraine
[Applause]
analysts say the weapons in the American
package such as long-range howitzers are
especially suited to Ukraine's defense
of the Eastern donbass region
so you want systems like that that can
fire you know 30 40 kilometers away from
where you are
trying to break up the military long
before he gets close to you and that's
what ukrainians need at this moment they
need to destroy the Russian comboys
before they even get to the cities or
near to the locations they want to take
the Pentagon said it was rushing to send
the equipment but did not provide a
timetable
for the people in the Eastern Ukrainian
city of sievero Donetsk something as
simple as walking to get groceries is a
calculated risk that could end in
tragedy
War has brought life to a standstill
it's a disaster
every 10 or 15 minutes Bam Bam
I live on the seventh floor of a
nine-floor building just imagine boom
from one side Bam from the other and
then you think the roof will cave in and
kill you
for some the fighting is too much to
bear
a bus takes them away from the bombs
but others are staying behind hoping to
survive the Russian advance
if weapons from the U.S don't stop it
first
and for more on this let's bring in our
correspondent Alexandra Von Naman in
Kiev Alexandra we just heard about a big
American announcement is Ukrainian
government hoping other nations will
follow suit
well no doubt about that in a video
addressed yesterday president zielinski
urged other Western Nations to provide
Ukraine with heavy weapons because of
course everyone here understands that
this is a crucial moment and as the
battlefield shifts the weapons that the
Ukrainian forces need are also changing
and president zielinski said that what
they need is long-range artillery tanks
armored vehicles air defense systems and
of course he has been repeating it for
many weeks now a combat Jets to protect
civilians and Ukrainian forces from
Russian missiles and airstrikes
and Ukraine is saying it expects a
Russian offensive in the East imminently
what more do we know about that
well we know that the Ukrainian
government has been bracing for a major
Russian offensive in the eastern and the
Southeastern part of the country they
have been warning that Russia was
messing their troops there that Russia
was moving more troops towards the
strategically important city of izum and
now the assessment is apparently that
Russia is ready and we know that the
goal would be there to take over to take
full control of the Donetsk region and
of course to capture the city of
mariopol because then the Russian forces
would be able to secure and land bridge
between their forces in their units in
Crimea and their units in the eastern
part of Ukraine and just a question
about Mario Paul that poor if I'm a
Russia is claiming that large numbers of
Ukrainian troops have surrendered there
and what does the Ukrainian government
say
they say they cannot confirm this
information instead they are saying that
some of the Marines trapped there
encircled by the Russian forces were
able to link up with other Ukrainian
forces still there fighting in the city
of marupol however they have
acknowledged that Russia is controlling
some areas in the Southeastern part of
mayupu and the situation there in
general is really dire with 10 of tens
of thousands of civilians still trapped
according to the mayor more than 20 000
civilians were killed there so the
situation is real really dire and the
Russian army is apparently intensifying
their assault on the city
okay Alexander Von namin reporting for
us from Kiev
the flagship of the Russian Black Sea
Fleet the muskva has been badly damaged
after an onboard explosion apparently
the Russian defense Ministry said the
incident was caused by a fire that the
ship's Ammunition Depot the ministry did
not specify the cause of Ablaze but said
the entire crew of 500 Sailors was
evacuated earlier a Ukrainian official
said the ship had been hit by two
missiles but did not give any evidence
for the claim